Hello everyone
Welcome to jadam
In this episode I m going to talk about how
to use and store the JADAM Natural pesticide.
Here I have prepared Jadam wetting agent,
jadam sulfur and Jadam herbal solution.
With this combination you are getting perfect
natural pesticide for your garden.
And in this vdeo I will show you how mix all
the solution in proper way.
This is Jadam herbal solution.
Which is the extract of any herbs with insect
repellent effect.
And usual herbs that are often used is pepper
mint, rose marry, lavender, Jerusalem artichoke,
and bracken.
Recently we have been testing the cosmos (flower)
and it is showing significant result.
With all these plants you can control aphid
and mite.
But above all our most favorite plant is the
gingko until now.
Because there is not a single pest that we
won t be able to control with this plant.
All the details and ratio are recorded in
my book JADAM Organic Farming and JADAM Organic
Pest and Disease control.
Briefly speaking, It is very simple to make
plant extracts.
All you need is to boil the plant for 5 hours.
And more detail information is spoken in my
lecture.
So please click the link above to see the
lecture video.
The first thing I would like to talk about
is how to store the herbal solution.
Once you are done with the boiling the herbs.
Pour the solution in a bottle and put in a
side way so that it will be vacuumed sealed.
In this way you can store the herbal solution
for couple of years.
But the problem is when you opened it for
use.
Because when it contacts with the air, The
properties of the solution start to change
gradually which cause decrease in its insecticidal
function.
Easy way to identify that the solution is
usable or not is the air pressure of the bottle
due to fermentation.
But to make sure, best way is to drop small
portion of JADAM wetting agent into it.
Once you drop the JWA, if the color of the
JHS doesn t change, that means it is still
good for use.
The another problem is how to properly store
a opened bottle.
Even if you put into refrigerator, the changes
cannot be stopped.
So best way is to get a help of ethanol.
There are usually two types of ethanol sold
in a market,.
One is with 84% purity and the other one is
with 99% purity.
When you are using 99% ethanol, add 15% of
ethanol from what is left over.
And 84% with 25%.
With the help of the ethanol you can increase
the shelf life of JADAM herbal solution even
in atmospheric temperature.
When non of herbs are available near you,
You can also use the sodium hydroxide as an
alternative.
And the ratio is 1 kilo of sodium hydroxide
for 500 liters and 40 grams for 20 liters.
With sodium hydroxide you can treat a problem
of scale insects and snail.
However, I do not recommend constant use of
this substance because of concentration damage.
JWA is recommended to use around 200 to 600
ml for 20 liters and 5 to 15 liters for 500
Liters.
JS is 40 ml to 60 ml for 20 liters
And JHS is 200 ml to 600 ml for 20 liters.
Recently, We have been receiving lot of question
from floweriest and Gardner about our JADAM
solution.
So let me elaborate how to combine all three
solution for pest and disease control.
This is the spray tool that I use for testing
the solution first before the field test.
This particular brand of spray is my favorite
due to its long lasting durability.
It cost little more but this is a product
worth to checkout.
Since we are testing 1 liter of small amount,
thing that we measure the ratio also have
to be syringes.
Before doing mixing process.
Please do use soft water.
It is mandatory in order to achive it s full
capability.
And now, Iet me show you how the disinfectant
is made.
I will measure 800 ml of soft water.
First I will add 10 ml of JADAM Wetting agent.
Next, 2ml of JADAM Sulfur.
This yellowish liquid is the natural disinfectant.
It can treat downy mildew, powdery mildew
and anthracnose.
Speaking of anthracnose, you can also control
this just by increasing the JWA,
As you can see JADAM s Natural pest solutions
are very easy to do with best effect on pest
and disease control.
And by adding JADAM Herbal solution, It becomes
all purpose natural pest and disease solution.
Then add a little more water to make it 1
full liter.
Best thing about JADAM solution, unlike any
commercially available chemical solutions.
JADAM solution is very safe to use.
There will be no big problem even it is contacted
on our skin.
You can also just wash the fruit to eat right
after spraying.
JADAM Natural pest solution is all about the
combination of JWA, JS and JHS.
To increase insecticidal effects, all you
need to do is increasing the amouing of JWA
and JHS.
And for disinfectant increase JS.
But do concentration test in advance for JS
before spraying into crops.
In this way you can control almost all pest
and disease,
You can add additional sodium hydroxide and
red clay powder for scale insect and snail.
Let me show you how to add them
Just add the sodium hydroxide in a beaker
with water to melt it down.
This is very useful for scale insect.
And red clay powder is for increasing penetration
effect.
With this simple you don t have to worry about
the pest and disease that occurs during farming.
However, when you are adding sodium hydroxide,
the solution can irritate your skin when it
makes a contact.
I have also made all the detail videos how
to all of these.
It is also stated in my book so that you can
read one for your self.
Thank you for watching and I will see you
guys in the next video.